Speaker 1: If you want to see a sign of
how bad things are in parts of the country,
the first openly gay mayor of an Oklahoma town
has resigned because of threats to his security
and harassment. Now I want to mention openly gay
is not a term I usually use because I agree. When
you say openly gay, you're sort of saying like
there is shame around being gay. And so we have
this category secretly gay and openly gay. Like,
I understand that. But the point here is we're
talking about someone who acknowledges publicly
as part of their public presence that they're gay.
And this is the first such mayor in Oklahoma.
And it's relevant to the story. But don't come
after me about openly gay. I get it. The first
openly gay mayor of a small town in Oklahoma
City is resigning after an increase in threats to
his safety. The village mayor, Adam Graham, who
took on the role in May, said in the last month
he's been followed home from meetings, threatened
with walking my dog, harassed at Starbucks and
have had my tires slashed. He says. Since 2018,
a fight against ageism, racism and homophobia at
every step. Unfortunately, certain elements of
the population have recently become emboldened to
pursue threats and attacks bordering on violence.
The threats from the past month resulted from an
incident two months ago where I stood up against
Nichols Hill police targeting the village
residents. Unfortunately, these malicious,
bad faith attacks are escalating, and I no longer
feel safe to serve in my capacity as mayor. It is
with a heavy heart. I tender my resignation.
Sickening country. And you know what? I can't
blame him. And yet, in a sense, the terrorists
win when this happened. Right. You terrorize the
gay mayor out of office and then you perpetuate
that. Probably the person who replaces him is
going to be heterosexual. And you perpetuate the
homophobia. They get a win. It's not a criticism
of the individual. I get it. I understand why
he's doing it. But at the same time, this is
sort of like how they win. So a very sad story.
And this is not I'm not even this is not whatever
country you'd imagine this happens in. This is the
United States in 2022. And the openly gay mayor
is afraid, essentially for his safety because of
the level of harassment, people following him,
stalking, etc., because he's gay. What
else can you say? Extraordinarily sad.